ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه جديده
من العربيه سنخصص معظمها لتغطيه التطورات
في السودان ونبدا بالعناوين
الامم المتحده تعلن نزوح اكثر من 70 الف
شخص من السودان وتحذر من وصول العادات الى
800 الف
وقوات الدعم السريع تتهم الجيش باستخدام
المستشفيات في المعارك والجيش يؤكد انها
تروع المواطنين
والمبعوثه للسودان يعلن موافقه طرفي
الصراع على ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض
وكذلك في هذه الساعه
100 الالف من المتظاهرين في شوارع فرنسا
احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد واشتباكات مع
الشرطه
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل الهدوء
النسبيه الذي فرضته الهدى السابقه في
السودان لا يبدو انه سيتكرر في هذه الهدنه
ففي الخرطوم بحري وفي احياء مختلفه من
الخرطوم ارتفعت وتيره الاشتباكات بين
الجانبين مع تصاعد اعمده الدخان في مشهد
يشبه الايام الاولى للاشتباكات وتقول قوه
الدعم السريع ان الجيش يواصل اختراق
الهدنه فيما يؤكد الجيش انه سيتصدى لمخطط
خطف البلاد كما يقول ووسط الاتهامات
المتبادلات تؤكد الامم المتحده وجود بادره
امل لانهاء هذه الاشتباكات عبر ارسال
الجانبين مندوبين من اجل التفاوض ولكن الى
ان يجلس الجانبان على الطاوله تتعاقد
الاوضاع المعيشيه بالنسبه للسودانيين
الذين اصبحت اصوات اطلاق الرصاص بالنسبه
لهم امرا طبيعيا
البلد ما امنه ما بقدر طبعا على الوضع بقى
صعب اشوف الشعب طبعا ما بيعرف
لازم واحد تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يشتغل القواد
ما حبابه والخوف ما منه فايده
[موسيقى]
متابعه بالتفاصيل مع زمينا مباشره من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده سلطاننا
السلميه الذي يتابع وصول سفينه جلاله
الملك ابها وعلامتها اكثر من 200 شخص تم
اجلاؤهم من السودان سلطان كيف هي صوره
وكيف هي تفاصيل من عندك
كما يظهر امام التواجد على متن السفينه
جلاله الملك ابها هذه السفينه وصلت قبل
عشر دقائق من الان وهي قادمه من ميناء
بورت السودان وعلى متنها نتحدث عن 212
راكبا من اثنين عشره جنسيه او جنسيه نتحدث
انه بدات عمليات الانزال لخمس حالات
الصحيه واحده منها سوف يتم نقلها الى اقرب
مستشفى للتعامل معها الان بدات عمليه
الانزال كما نشاهد اثناء اثني عشره جنسيه
باختلاف اعمارهم
والحالات الصحيه الخاصه بهم نتحدث عن وجود
41 مواطن سعودي على متن هذه السفينه التي
اتت من ميناء بورت السودان واستغرقت
الرحله قرابه العشر ساعات ايضا التحدث عن
تنوع كبير في الجنسيات من افغانستان ومن
السودان ومن فلبين ومن جزر القمر سريلانكا
ومن اوكرانيا ومن مدغشقر وكذلك من امريكا
بريطانيا وسوريا
والفريق ايضا نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره وصلت
على متن هذه السفينه نتحدث على 200 واثنى
عشر راكبا واذ وصل عدد الكلي بعد نزول
هؤلاء الرعايه من علامات هذه السفينه الى
ارض قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه عن
5409 من الرعايه وصلوا الى مدينه جده عبر
مختلف
المواقع تتحدث عن قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده او حتى عبر الاخلاء الجوي لقاعه
الملك عبد الله الجويه وايضا عبر ميناء
جده الاسلامي تم نقل هؤلاء الرعايه من
ميناء بورت سودان الى مدينه جده وتحديدا
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه وسط حمايه من
القوات الخاصه البحريه المتواجده على متن
هذه السفينه للتامين وصولها هؤلاء الرعايه
الى مدينه جده نتحدث ان هذه الرحله رقم 14
من ضمنها رحلتين مدنيه كانت عبر سفينه
تسمى امال نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره له ؤلاء
الرعايه الذين يصلون بشكل يومي عبد
الرحلات عسكريه متعدده من ميناء بورت
سودان الى مدينه جده وتحديدا لعرض قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده اكرر انه التزال
لا تزال الرحلات متواصله
بشكل مستمر اتصل من ميناء بورت سودان
رحلات الاجلاء السعوديه عبر القوات
الملكيه البحريه السعوديه وصولا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل في استقبالهم
نتابع معك هذه الصور
فقط ان نستفسر عن الترتيبات يعني الواصلون
بعد نزولهم من السفينه الى اين يتوجهون ما
هي الترتيبات او ما هي الاجراءات التي
خصصتها لهم مسعوديه
كافه الرعايه ممن وصلوا الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده او الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه او حتى الى قائله ميناء جده
الاسلامي وصلوا الى جده فتم استقبالهم من
قبل سفراء وقناصل دولهم وكذلك برفقه او
بوجود ممثلين من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
وكذلك عدد من قطاعات الحكوميه للتعامل
واستقبال وانهاء اجراءات دخولهم الى
الاراضي السعوديه ويتم استقبالهم بالورد
والحلوى حتى يصلوا الى القاعده ومن ثم
انهاء اجراءات السفر في ظرف الساعه واحده
وبعد ذلك يتم عمليه نقلهم عبر اسطول من
الحافلات الى مقرات السكن المخصصه له من
قبل السلطات السعوديه حتى يتسنى بعد ذلك
استعدادهم للسفر الى بلدانهم لانه شاهد
امامكم وصور مباشره وجود عدد من السفراء
والقناص الاستقبال الرعايه مباشره بعد
نزولهم علامه السفينه جلاله الملك ابها
يتم استقبالهم الرعايه يتم اخذ صور
الجوازات الخاصه بهم كذلك يتم منحهم
ومنحهم تاشيره لمده شهر من قبل المديريه
العامه للجوازات وهذه التاشيره هي
استشيرها استثنائيه لهؤلاء الرعايه لسيما
هم يعيشون ظرف انساني مختلف ومعاناه كبيره
عاشوا تفاصيلها هناك في السودان في ظل
اشتباكات المسلحه الان يتم اخذهم بعد
استقبالهم من السفراء والقناصل وكذلك
ممثلي وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه يتم
استقبالهم ومن ثم انهاء اجراءات دخول من
اراضي السعوديه في ظرف ساعه واحده وبعد
ذلك يتم نقلهم عبر اسطول من الحافلات الى
اربعه فنادق ضخمه وكبيره في جده خاصه
السلطات السعوديه لهؤلاء الرايه ومن ثم
بعد ذلك في ظرف 48 الساعه يستعد هؤلاء
الرعايه لانهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم
ومن ثم يتم او يستطيعون السفر عبر مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده كما كانت
هنالك رحلات اجلاء كانت من مطار جده الى
الهند يوم امس وكذلك خلال يومين الماضيه
اكثر من 347 مواطن صيني تغادروا الاراضي
السعوديه من مطار جده الى العاصمه الصينيه
بكينها والعمليه تتم بهذا الشكل نعم اود
شكرا جزيلا شكرا زميلنا سلطان السلمي مع
وصول سفينه جلاله الملك
ابها وتبعنا معه كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا لك
سلطان
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف انه الواحد
يكون كله يعني قوه والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كتيره هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كثير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه هل هذا الاستق
بال
[موسيقى]
في تطورات اخرى كان اعلن مسؤول اللاجئين
في الامم المتحده توقعاته بفرار ما يفوق
عن 800 الف شخص من السودان اثر النزاع في
البلاد كما اضاف المسؤول ان ثلاثا وسبعين
الف شخص فرو متجهين الى دول الجوار وفي
سياق ذاته عبر مناسق الامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه عن مخاوفه من امتداد ازمه
السودان الى دول الجوار واعلن المنسق ان
الوضع الانسانيه في البلاد يتجه الى نحو
كارثي وان شحنه من الادويه عالقه على
الحدود ولم تدخل السودان بعد
اتهم الدعم السريع الجيش السوداني بتحويل
مستشفى السلاح الطبي بعم درمان الى منصه
للقصف المدفعي واشار في بيان له الى ان
القذف المدفعي العشوائي من مستشفى السلاح
الطبي الدالي مقتل واصابه الكوادر طبيه
بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريعه واضاف ايضا ان
طيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق في سماء الخرطوم
ويقصف احياء سكنيه
هذا وكان الجيش السوداني قد اكد في بياننا
ان قوات الدعم السريع حشدت اكثر من 65 الف
عنصر والف مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
تصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيره الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان
يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف مضيفا انه تم احباط عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من اتجاه الغرب الى الخرطومه
في المقابل كانت نشرت قوه الدعم السريع
لقطات فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى
القصر الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت
قوه دعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على
القصر الجمهوري ومحيطه في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في
اندرمان كما اكد احد قاده الدعم السريع ان
سيطرتهم على القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن
مساعي الدعم السريع للحفاظ على ثروات
الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان اوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب
المسلح بان هذا العمل الذي زدت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين على سلطه الشعب السوداني وعن
طريق كوميتو نحن الان في قوات الدعم
السريع بالناشد كل القوات المسلحه وشرفاء
القوات المسلحه بانه نحن ما عاد بالنسبه
لهم وانما نحن نريد ان نحافظ على سلطه
الشعب ونقول للشعب السوداني تواجد قوات
الدعم السريع في داخل القصر وفي كل ولايه
الخرطوم القرض الاساسي منه الحفاظ على
سلطه الشعب
قال المبعوث الامم للسودان قال ان طرف
يسرع وافق على ارسال مندوبنا للتفاوض بين
الجانبين واضاف بيرتز في حديث لوكاله
السوشيت بريس ان المحادثات تعقد على
الارجح في السعوديه المبعوث الاممي قال ان
التفاوض سيركز في المقام الاول على ترسيخ
وقف اطلاق النار بشكل مستمر وموثوق مع وضع
فكره انشاء اليه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار
تضم مراقبين سودانيين واجانب
وفي تصريحات اخرى حول الاوضاع الانسانيه
قال بيرتس ان العديد من المساعدات
الغذائيه الخاصه بالامم المتحده تم نهبها
مشيرا الى ان الوضع في السودان اصبح
كارثيا بحسب وصفه
العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه التي كانت
موجوده في المخازن تم نهبها كل المخازن
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين في دارفور مركبات وكالات الاغاثه
تعرضت للسرقه مكاتبي ايضا في دارفور تعرضت
للسرقه لم يتم احترامه وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل كان الالتزام جزئيا وفي مواقع
دون اخرى
الالاف من السودانيين النزوح من مناطقهم
هربا من الاقتتال الدائر فيما يتجه كثيرون
الى بورتسودان من خلال حافلات لنقل الركاب
باتت تكلفتها اغلى من المعتاد بسبب نقص
الوقود ويقول الاهالي في ام درمان ان
العائلات تتجه الى مواقف الحافلات سيرا
على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر وسائل للنقل مع
استمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه
الخرطوم للولايات فبرده يعني الحاجه صعبه
شديد يعني اول كلمه خاشش الشعبي لقيت دفار
بعشره
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر فما بالك يعني
باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
ومعنا من الخرطوم وراس العربيه يا سلام
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا نبدا باخر
تطورات الميدانيه معك
نعم اخر التطورات الميدانيه هو ان هنالك
قصف الان في محيط مطار الخرطوم وكذلك في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش الطائرات تتبع
القوات الجويه السودانيه تستهدف المناطق
التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم السريع وفي
هذه المناطق كانت قوات الدعم السريع قد
انتشرت بالقرب من مطار الخرطوم الجنوبي
مطار الخرطوم وكذلك الجنوب الغربي من مطار
الخرطوم هذه هي المناطق التي كانت
ترتكز فيها قوات الدعم السريع وكان الجيش
السوداني يستهدف بقصفه هذه المناطق كان
قصفا متواصلا بقرابه الساعه قبل نصف ساعه
من الان ما زالت حتى قبل قليل تحلق هذه
الطائرات ونستمع الى مضادات للطائرات في
هذه الاثناء اندلع حريق في احد المنازل
وهو الان من خلفك ما نتابعه الان في
الشاشه هذا الحريق لم يعرف ما هي اسباب
هذا الحريق حتى الان هناك من يقول انه
بسبب الطائرات وهناك من يقول انه لا يعلم
لا يعرف ما هي اسباب هذا الحريق اللافت
للانتباه ان هذا الحريق اطفئه شباب الحي
بمجه ود شعبي وما زالوا يواصلون في اطفاء
هذا الحريق لوحدهم دون تدخل من اي جهات
وما هاهم الان مواصلين في العمل لاطفاء
هذا الحريق تماما ايضا لله الحمد لا توجد
اي اصابات في هذه المنطقه او في هذا
الحريق
نعم ونحن نتابع هذه الصور المباشره مع
زميلنا سالم الهاشمي يتحدث عن حريق تقول
سالم بان اسباب الحريق غير معلومه حتى
الان ان كانت نتيجه لقصف او
اسباب اخرى ولكنك تؤكد بان طيران الجيش
حلق في مدن الخرطوم واستهدف مواقع لدعم
السريع سنبقى مع هذه الصور وحدثنا كذلك عن
الاشتباكات في تخوم العاصمه بمعنى ان
البعض يقول بان حددتها ارتفعت خاصه في
الساعات الاخيره تؤكد لنا ذلك وماذا في
تفاصيل هذه الاشتباكات
الجديد في هذه الاشتباكات انها تجددت في
مدينه بحري وكذلك في مدينه ام درمان حتى
هذا القصف طال هذه المناطق وهذه المناطق
في غالبها تتمركز بها قوات للدعم السريع
في مدينه بحري الان كان هنالك قصف قبل
قليل في منطقه كافوري مربع سته في وسط
مدينه بحري بالقرب من المنطقه الصناعيه
وفي هذه المنطقه يوجد معسكر بمعسكرات قوات
الدعم السريع يضاف الى ذلك بقيه المناطق
التي تتمركز بها هذه القوات تشن القوات
الجويه السودانيه هذه الحمله على كل قوات
الدعم السريعه التي اكد الجيش السوداني
انها قوات متمرده وانه لابد من القضاء
عليها
على كل سنعود لك مع ابرز واخر التطورات
شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الانسه لما الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
ونتابع مشاهدينا معنا من ام درمان الصحفي
في مكتب العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر
شهدي اهلا بك معنا او فصل الاتصال طيب
سنعود لشهده بعد قليل او هو جاهز معنا
شهدي اهلا بك كما رصدنا تفاصيل في الخرطوم
نردها كذلك معك في اندرمان كيف هي صوره
نعم يستمر السلاح الجو السوداني طائرات
مقاتله في التحليق بكثافه لاكثر من ساعتين
اصوات المضادات الارضيه ايضا اطلاق مكثف
للمضادات العرضيه تحديدا في الاصوات تاتي
من منطقه جنوب ام درمان هذا الامر مستمر
لاكثر من ساعتين ثم قص
للطيران المقاتل كذلك نشاهد الشرق مدينه
ام درمان ايضا تاتي من هناك اصوات
المضادات واتجاه
الطيران
المقاتل جهود عيان اكدوا ان اتمت قصف في
ضاحيه كافوري وقوات الدعم السريع اتهمت
القوات المسلحه بانها قد قصفت
سلاح المظلات بضاحيه الشنبات هو سلاح كان
يدوقات المسلحه وتم تحويله ليكون وحده
اطبيه تم اصدر بيان من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع تفيد بان الموقع يتعرض لقص مدفعي
اليوم خلف اضرار
واصابات وسطه
الجرح تقول شهدي فقط لنفهم هذا التفصيل
تقول بان احدى النقاط التي كانت تتمركز
فيها قوات الدعم السريع حولتها لوحده طبيه
فتم استهدافها كيف تم ذلك
هي في الاساس يتم تحويلها منذ زمن بعيد
لتكون وحده طبيه هذه بحسب البيان انها قد
تعرضت اليوم لقصف كان بها عدد من الجرحى
من العسكريين كانوا يتلقون العلاج بحسب ما
ذكر بيان الدعم القوات القوات الدعم
السريع بحسب ما ذكر بيانها بانه اليوم
تعرض لاقص خلف اضرار خلف جرحى ومصابين وسط
القوات التي تتواجد هناك في تلك المنطقه
الملاحظ انه منذ منتصف نهار اليوم الطيران
يحلق بكثافه في سماء العاصمه بمدنها
الثلاثه شهود عيان ايضا ذكروا بان ضاحيه
شرق النيل تشهد اشتباكات وهكذا تحليق
للطيران ونحن نتكلم الان شهدي هناك صور
مباشره من الخرطوم هي صور قبل قليل سنتابع
هذه الصور ونعود لنعلق عليها ونفهم مصدرها
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين كلنا مع هذه الصور صور نستمع من
خلالها
لاشتباكات بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني سنتابع كل هذه التفاصيل
ولكن اعود لك من جديد شهدي اندرمان مهمه
لمكانها الجغرافي وكذلك
لكونها معبر عبر الولايات وبالتالي هل
تشهد او هل بدا تشهد حاله نزوح كبيره خاصه
وانك حضرت نفس ساعات الماضيه عن ان هذه
المنطقه قد تختلف على بقيه الولايات بما
ان سكانها متمسكين بالبقاء فيها فهل بدات
تتغير الصوره مع توسع نطاق الاشتباكات في
الساعات الاخيره
لا الحال كما هو بالنسبه لسكانها هي لا
تشهد حالات نزوح لسكانها باستثناء بعض
المناطق في جنوبها اندرمان كما تعلمي بها
احد اكبر المحطات
الحافلات السفريه التي تنقل المواطنين برا
الى الولايات الى الولايات الشماليه وكذلك
حتى الى داخل جمهوريه مصر العربيه هناك
سوق ومحطه معروفه تسمى محطه قندهار منها
تنطلق الحافلات السفريه لتجوب ولايات
الولايات الشماليه هي هذه المحطه هي التي
تعد مقصد كل راقب وكل من اضطرته الظروف
الامنيه الى مغادره
العاصمه الخرطوم الى الى خارجها سوائل
الولايات الشماليه او الى داخل مصر او الى
الولايه الشماليه ومنها عفوا نعم الى
الولايه الشماليه ومنها الى ولايه البحر
الاحمر وتحديدا مدينه بورسودان في شرق
في الشرق في شرق السودان
سنتابع كل هذا شكرا جزيلا لك شهد نادر
الصحفي في مكتب
انا انظر معي شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا يواجه السودانيون خطر المواجهات
العسكريه بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع
الدائره منذ ثلاثه اسابيع وعلى الرغم من
الاوضاع الامنيه المترديه يضطر كثيرون الى
التوجه الى اعمالهم ووظائفهم المختلفه
لاعاله اسرهم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه
وانسانيه صعبه
لازم اشتغل يعني
اي حاجه زايده لازم انا اشتغل يعني
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما امنه
ما في يعني اي حاجه
شهدت عده مخابز شرق العاصمه الخرطوم عوده
تدريجيه للعمل وسطى قله الموارد وانعدام
الامن نتابع الناس بامانه تعبت يعني في
ناس تعبت كثير في اطفال
فقدت حياته في اسر تعبت لكن الان الحمد
لله تفتح
والامور ماشيه الاخيره ربنا يصلح الحال
وضع سيء وضع سيء للغايه
لابعد الحدود
وفي متابعه لعمليات الاجلاء توافد المئات
من الرعايه الى من البرتغال ضمن عمليه
الاجراء المستمره هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
نحن الان هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق
السودان سناخذ جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا
المركز الرئيسي الذي يضم مئات من الاسر
الذي التي بدات في التوافد الى مدينه
بورسودان نبدا بالجهد الشعبي الذي يوازي
هذه الاعداد الكثيفه الان هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ممثله في غرفه الطوارئ عملت على
توفير هذا المستشفى المؤقت وهذه الغرفه
المؤقته للطوارئ للتعامل مع عدد من
الحالات التي قد ترد الى هذه المنطقه
حالات لسوريين وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم
الخدمات في هذا المركز الذي انشا قبل
يومين في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما
ذكرنا عددا من السوريين وعددا من اليمني
ين وايضا اضيفت اليهم نسبه اخرى من
المقيمين السودانيين الذين يحاولون ايضا
عبر هذا المركز ان يغادروا هذه المنصه هنا
في شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول عبر من
بورسودان
ومشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور المتداوله لما
قيل بانه طيران للجيش قصفه ولايه شرق
النيل
وميدانيا يبدو بان هناك ذلك اشتباكات على
الارض اذا هذه صور متداوله لما قيل انه
قصف على ولايه شرق النيل من طيران الجيش
السوداني
[موسيقى]
حنا تقريبا حوالي
345000 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبره وعلى
الكورنيش الناس تكون في الارض ارامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني
اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين
اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتيه من الخرطوم
قال عبيده دندراوي نائب المندوب الدائم
لمصر في الجامعه العربيه قال ان مصر
استقبلت 40 الف سوداني منظومه الازمه
الالتزام بالوقفه الفوري والشامل للقتال
فالى الاولويه لمصلحه الشعب السوداني يجب
ان تظهر من خلال مبادره الاطراف ببذل كافه
مساعيها لحقن الدماء
وهو شرط اساسي للعوده للحوار السياسي
الحتمي الذي يمكن من خلاله حل الازمه بشكل
شامل استقبال مصر حتى صباح اليوم ما يقارب
اربعين الف مواطن سوداني اضافي عبر معبري
ارقين وقسطل بالحدود المصريه الجنوبيه
هذا ويواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغ عددهم
حوالي 45 مليون نسمه يواجهون ازمه غذاء
متصاعدا ما دفع مسؤوله الاتصال في برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه لوصف الوضع الانساني في
البلاد بالكارثيه معاناه على معاناه تجثم
على قلوب السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محلهم
التجاريه او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق
السودان يشكو ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات
سابقه متداخله الوضع الانساني كارثي او
كما وصفه الامين العام للامم المتحده بلغ
نقطه الانهيار
السودان على السلطه في السودان لا يعرض
مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه يضيء
فتيله يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود ويسبب
معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه الى
الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه خمسه عشر مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي ومع اندلاع
الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه عشره
تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب اغلاق
ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور التحدي
الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
هذا مشاهدينا ويشهد السودان في اليوم
السابع عشر هدوءا حذرا رغم بعض الخروقات
التي وقعت في الساعات الماضيه حيث شهد
محيط القصر الرئاسي اطلق نار باسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه واشتباكات متقطعه وقصيره في شارع
المطار بحسب مراسل العربيه وعلى الضفه
المقابله للقصر الجمهوري في منطقه حله
حماه بخرطوم بحري سمع في ساعات الصباح
اطلاق نار وذوي مضادات ارضيه لدعم السريع
اما في اقصى الجنوب الغربي من الخرطوم
فاقد حلقت مقاتله الجيش فوق منطقه جبل
اولياء والى شمال من بحر ايضا سمع اطلاق
نار بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه تحديدا في
ضاحيه شنباته
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من القاهره
عادل سيد احمد الصحفي السوداني سيد عادل
اهلا بك معنا مبدئيا اسمح لي ان ابدا معك
بوضع الواصلين الى مصر هل لديك بعض
المعلومات التي يمكن ان توضح لنا وضعهم
كيف يتم او ما الترتيبات التي خصصت لهم
خاصه واننا نتحدث عن ما يفوق الاربعين الف
سوداني وصلوا منذ بدء الازمه الى مصر
مرحبا بك وبكل مشاهدي قناه العربيه حقيقه
نحن تابعنا بتفاصيل دقيقه
خروج الكثير جدا من اهلنا من السودان في
طريقهم الى الشقيقه مصر وقد كانت الرحله
من الخرطوم الى المعابر رحله صعبه جدا
وشاقه حيث كان الطريق
محفوفا بالكثير جدا من الارتكازات التي
تضم
عناصر تتبع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وعناصر تتبع للدعم السريع لذلك كان طريقه
مرعبا جدا
الرحله المعاناه وصل من بعدها النازحون
الى منطقتي حلفا وشمال شركه السودان حيث
ارجين كانت هناك معاناه كبيره جدا في في
السكن
وفي التذاكر وفي الطعام وما الى ذلك ولكن
المعبرين اللي هم معبر من حلف الى قسطل او
من او نعم او او عبر ارجين وهما المعبرين
اللي من خلالهم دخل السودانيين الى مصر
الاجراءات رغم التكدس ورغم الاقتصاص
الكبير ولكن الاجراءات كانت سلسه جدا
بدليل ان القائمين على امر هذه الاجراءات
كانوا يتواجدون لساعات طويله جدا
لمواكبه هذا العدد الكبير من السودانيين
الذين دخلوا الى مصر الاجراءات كانت تتم
بسلاسه
بدون تعقيدات ولكن متى بعد الوصول ما هو
وضعهم ما هي حالتهم هل هناك ترتيبات
للابقاء عليهم في مكان معين مثلا فانتظار
ان تهدا الازمه هل هناك تخطيط اذا ما طالت
هذه الازمه والبعض يرجح ان يطول امدها كيف
تتعامل معهم الجهات المصريه اعلم حضرتك
بانك السوداني ولكن اكيد بانك عايش في مصر
وتتابع عن قرب هذا الوضع وهذه التفاصيل
نعم
الوفود التي حضرت من السودان عقب الحرب
تم عمل الى تسهيلات شديده جدا في
الاجراءات اجراءات التاشيره وما الى ذلك
وهذا بالطبع كان يعني قد تم
تقديرا لظروف الحرب التي وقعت في السودان
ولكن حتى الان
يعني دخول السودانيين اتى بهذه الطريقه
ومعظم اتوا يعني بطريقه لم تكن فيها البعد
بعد اللاجئين بقدر ما كان هناك تسهيل من
السلطات المصريه لدخول هذه المجموعات
تقدير لظرف الحرب الذي يمر به السودان حتى
الان تحدثنا
طالما بدانا نتحدث عن هذه الفرضيات التي
ترى بان امد هذه الازمه قد يطول خاصه وان
كل وسائل الاعلام بدات يعني تركز على
موضوع النزوح وموضوع اللجوء وهذا يذكرنا
في الواقع بازمات سابقه بحروب سابقه التي
طالماها ولازلنا الى اليوم نغطيها نتحدث
مثلا عن الحرب الاوكرانيه وبالتالي حضرتك
هل ترى بان هذه الازمه ازمه يمكن ان تطول
فعلا او هناك محاولات
لايجاد حلول لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار وفيما
بعد العوده للمسار السياسي
التي يرغب في طرحها استاذ عادل بان عوده
الاشتباكات لما كانت عليه في الايام
الاولى قد تكون مؤشرا الى خطه معينه في
يعني بموازات هذه الاشتباكات هناك خطه
معينه تحذر مثلا لفرض جلوس الاطراف على
طويله واحده
انا اعتقد انه
القوات المسلحه السودانيه والدعم السريع
كلاهما يحاول ان يعزز موقفه خاصه ان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه والتي فيما يبدو
انها تقوم بعمليات تمشيط كبيره جدا بعد ان
حققت انتصارات في مواقع متعدده ولكن الدعم
السريع كذلك يريد ان يقول للعالم الذي
يشاهد هذه الماساه انه ايضا هو موجود في
الميدان لذلك الطرف الثالث الذي يرغب في
طرح مبادره لاجلاس الاطراف على ماده
التفاوض هذا الطرف من الممكن ان يوجه
نداءات وتحدث استجابه من الطرفين ولكن لان
لم تكن الاستجابه جاده من الطرفين فان
المجتمع الدولي والمجتمع الاقليمي له
وسائل اخرى لفرض اجنده الحوار طيب نحن
نتحدث عن طرفين نتحدث عن الدعم السريع
وكذلك عن الجيش السوداني ولكن ماذا عن
الاط راف الاخرى على الارض سيد عادل بمعنى
ان هناك تصريحات تؤكد بان اطراف اخرى هي
التي تريد ان تشتد هذه الازمه وعلى فكره
غوتيرش اخر مره في حواره الى العربيه اكد
هذا الموضوع او على الاقل خلينا نقول اشار
له ما موقف هذه الاطراف وباختصار ان تكرمت
نعم نعم واضح جدا وهذا الطرف لا يتردد في
ان يظهر نفسه بمظهر كما يقول اهلنا
السودانيون المدينه حركتني هذا الطرف هو
فلول النظام السابق فلول النظام السابق هم
يريدون ان يهدوا المعبد على السودانيين
نحن او الطوفان هذا هو لسان حاليم لذلك هم
المستفيدون حقيقه من هذه الحرب وممر
راغبون بجد على ان تستمر
ويهلك السودان طالما انهم خارج السلطه
شكرا جزيلا لك عادل سيد احمد صحفي
السوداني كنت معنا من القاهره
يصل الاف السودانيين الفارين الى الحدود
المصريه عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري لتكون
مدينه ابو سمبل الاولى محطات استقبالهم
اهل المدينه حرصوا على تقديم كافه انواع
المساعده للنازحين الهاربين من الاشتباكات
الداميه في بلادهم
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من بعبر قسطنب البري الوجوه المرهقه من
عناء الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع
استقبال اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود
المصريه الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين
ما تيسر من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي
السودان قبل استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه
اسوان احنا طبعا لازم نقف جنب شقاءنا
السودانيين في الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا
عملنا المبادره دي مع شباب القريه عندنا
وحسينا ان احنا اهل البلد يعني يعني
الخدمه اللي قدموها لنا ما حسستني انه ليس
مازلنا في السودان يعني بعض القادمين لا
يملكون الاموال اللازمه لاستكمال الرحله
احدى المجموعات النازحه توجهت الى وسط
المدينه لتفاجا برد فعل الاهالي الذين
قاموا بجمع المساعدات المطلوبه
والله انا
بقينا الكرم ولينا الضيافه ولينا منهم
والله كل خير يعني احنا نقوتهم في ابنائه
وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونه للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه بفضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعثاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنت الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني
كلهم بامان الناس كثيره هناك عندها مشاكل
ما قادره ما عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري
ناس كتير معلقه نحمد الله سبحانه وتعالى
والشكر لاهل المملكه هل هذا الاستحمام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات